hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in part three of his treatise on the
basis of morality arthur schopenhauer is
going to discuss justice and one of the
very interesting discussions that is
taking place in the heart of that
chapter
is going to be
how justice and injustice
rightness and wrongness literally
kite and um can admit of
quantitative differences now he begins
this part by saying with every unjust
action the wrong is
qualitatively
the same namely it involves some sort of
injury to
another and that he lists four different
ways in which this can occur this is not
a like absolutely comprehensive list but
it gives you an idea of the scope to the
person
uh in themselves as a person so perhaps
to their body
perhaps to their mind also to their
freedom interfering with the freedom
that they ought to have
or to their property or to their
honor
and
schopenhauer is saying that considered
in a qualitative
way
something either is right or it is wrong
and there's no
qualitative difference between different
wrongs different injuries
but
quantitatively
the amount of wrong can differ he says
quantitatively it can be very different
such difference in the amount of wrong
and then he goes on to say something
that's very interesting
about this
it's recognized in real life what is the
evidence for the fact that it's
recognized in real life we make these
distinctions we say that well they both
were wrong
but this person who
used greater force and you know killed
the person and this one just injured the
other person it was more wrong for them
to do that
and
schopenhauer is going to say
somewhat implausibly that this has been
overlooked
by
moralists right it has not been properly
investigated by moralists though it's
everywhere recognized in real life
now we should pause here for a moment
and ask ourselves is he being
a bit polemical or hyperbolic
i would say yes he is this certainly
does apply to some systems of morality
which say
things like well
you know if you're doing something wrong
it's just as wrong to do this thing this
small thing over here
which has very few consequences as it is
to do this massive thing over here
they're equally wrong right and we can
see we could interpret kant as saying
something like that
we could say that certain christian
rigorists are saying things like that
the stoics
famously have a stoic paradox where they
say that you know all
goods are equal all evils are equal so
there's you know there's some people who
are
not recognizing this and he goes on and
he says that this is not just about
injustice this is also about the justice
of actions it can vary
quantitatively that is in a kind of
number or
amount now is this as simple as like
tallying things up or maybe making a
checklist or something like that no and
as a matter of fact at one point in here
he's going to say that
the measure of this very significant
difference in the quantity of justice
and injustice the quality always being
equal is not direct and absolute like on
a graduated scale
but indirect and relative and he invokes
a mathematical
idea here he says like
that of sines and tangents where there's
a curve
involved but then he's going to give us
some equations
for that which don't really
jive
with that explanation so you know we
have to figure out where we want to go
with this he does provide some helpful
examples so
he says whoever steals a loaf when dying
of starvation commits a wrong it is a
wrong it is an injustice right
but how small there is the quantity his
injustice is when compared with that of
a rich man who in any way defrauds a
poor man of his last possession
one of these is
very significant in terms of quantity
they're both equally wrong from a
qualitative point of view but they're
not equally wrong from a quantitative
point of view we can say that one is at
least quantitatively objectively worse
objectively more unjust
than the other and given the equations
that we have we might even be able to
directly compare these against each
other not in the like sine waves or
tangents or things like that but it you
know in with basic arithmetic
he also has another example which has to
do with justice the rich man who pays
his day labor acts justly good it's you
know
qualitatively it is the same as any
other action um paying your your work
people paying your employees what they
deserve is doing the right thing it's
easy for you because you got plenty of
money
but it's you know still the right thing
the poor man who voluntarily returns to
the rich man
the purse of gold he has found is doing
a
much greater
justice quantitatively again
than the rich person who is disbursing
you know
funds properly or something like that so
schopenhauer is going to go on and he's
going to say we can actually come up
with a
measure for this we can come up with
some formulas or you could even call
them equations if you wanted
and it's very interesting to see how
these are set up so let's look at both
of these we have injustice and we have
justice and both of them involve a kind
of
operation of
you know
giving some numbers and then doing some
division so they could each be
understood as kind of ratios which then
could be compared against each other
injustices could be quantitatively
compared against each other justices
could be quantitatively compared against
each other too so how do we figure this
out so let's look at injustice first
the injustice the amount the number of
injustice is that of the evil that i
inflict and so we you know if we're
going to quantify this we got to come up
with some sort of number maybe we talk
about the damage that's done to the
person the freedoms that have been taken
away the property that has to be
replaced
the degree of honor or something like
that so the evil that i inflict on a
another person
divided by
the amount of advantage that i
thereby
attain right
so
if i am
obtaining
a significant advantage we'll take the
man who is
starving and procures a loaf of bread by
stealing it right this is an age-old
example by the way and as a matter of
fact some moralists like thomas aquinas
would say the guy's not even stealing
schopenhauer is willing to say he is
stealing
but the amount of advantage that he's
getting keeping himself alive is very
great
whereas the evil that he's inflicting
the baker loses a loaf of bread the
baker has plenty of bread right they may
actually throw away some of the bread at
the end of the night so they really
didn't lose much of anything
maybe you could say well what about if
you know somebody came along and was
going to buy that loaf of bread for a
lot of money okay well then we would
change the numbers right
so the evil that is inflicted
divided by the amount of advantage it's
going to be a pretty small number
now let's take the example of the rich
man who takes from the poor man
his last possessions
throws him out in the street takes his
food burns his clothing something like
that the evil that's being inflicted is
significant
what is the rich man getting from it
maybe you could say well he enjoys
himself uh you know there's this
motivation of malice he really gets a
kick out of throwing people out of house
and home still going to be a pretty
small amount of advantage and so the
amount of injustice here is going to be
a large number divided by a small number
as opposed to the
converse and there'll be a lot more
injustice
in doing that
and you notice if we change the
numbers on either side right let's say
we try to minimize the amount of evil
that we inflict we thereby
lower the amount of injustice or if it
has to do with things where i said i
have to do this because i have to
provide for other people then maybe the
amount of advantage
is greater and if we're doing
bad things like bullying somebody just
to get a kick out of it well that's
probably going to be a lot of of
injustice right because the amount of
advantage is pretty small
what about justice so justice we look at
two other factors
and here it gets quite interesting the
advantage to me
that i had to
pass up or the way that he says it here
the advantage which the injury to
another would bring me right so by if i
weren't going to be just if i were going
to be unjust to this person what would i
get out of it right
um sort of like the amount of advantage
that i attain
then it's divided by the amount of harm
that the other would
suffer
right not to behave justly so
you know look at these two examples
again um the
rich man who pays his day laborer acting
justly there's a positive there right
they could have pocketed the money they
could have not paid them they could have
taken advantage of them and said get out
of here you know you uh
did the uh the the gardening but i'm not
going to pay you for it but we know rich
people who do that sort of thing right
the advantage is pretty small if you're
already rich
you know not paying a workman is not
going to
make that much of a difference to your
your pocketbook
but the amount of harm to the other
person is significant
right
and so
um
you know the advantage is is fairly
small the amount of harm is significant
so therefore you're going to wind up
with a small number of justice that is
being done
what about the poor person who sees the
rich person drop their purse in the
street
and you know it's got
say
10 years worth of their wages in it they
could pick it up
and keep it and they could live off of
that for a long long time it could help
them pay their debts it could provide
for their
you know spouse and family
so the advantage that is passed up is
quite significant right
and the harm that the rich person would
suffer it would be some losing your
purse in the street but the rich person
is rich so unless you know it's filled
with their entire life savings the
amount of harm is not particularly great
so it would be significant justice this
allows us
to compare
instances of injustice and justice
against each other in a quantitative way
and let's remind ourselves once again as
schopenhauer says qualitatively it's
either just or it's unjust and all
justice or injustice qualitatively is
the same but this quantitative thing is
very
very significant and that's why he
brings it up
there is one other factor that he
highlights as well and this is what he
calls a double injustice
says there's a double injustice
specifically different from every simple
one however great and this raises the
amount of injustice he says this is seen
through the amount of indignation
of the
impartial
witness the person who sees it and
they're like that is wrong that is bs
right
he says it's loathed and detested as
something revolting and outrageous as a
monstrous crime
what is it he says it occurs when anyone
has expressively undertaken the
obligation to protect someone else
in a definite respect consequently the
non-fulfillment of the obligation would
itself be an injury to the other person
and thus a wrong but in addition here's
the doubling he now attacks and injures
the other person at the very spot where
he should protect him so he gives some
prime examples of this
when the appointed watchman or attendant
becomes a murderer you're supposed to
protect this person you kill him instead
right where the trusted custodian
becomes a thief where the guardian
defrauds the ward of her property the
lawyer
prevaricates the lawyer lies right the
judge allows himself to be bribed and
the man asked for advice to liber
deliberately give some dangerous
and pernicious counsel and he says all
of these are types of treachery and then
he invokes dante and he says you want to
wind up way down there in the the very
bottom of the pit that's the way that
you behave so that is one way in which
the quantitative level
of injustice can be
raised significantly and attain a
higher number so this is how
schopenhauer thinks that we can
quantitatively distinguish between the
more and the less when it comes to
justice and injustice
you